[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo tuve como pocos colombianos un
privilegio muy grande y un lujo mientras
crecía y es que además de tener todas
las ventajas de crecer en bogotá con un
excelente sistema educativo todos los
fines de semana mis papás me llevaban a
la finca de mi abuela allá durante toda
mi infancia me fui acercando a la
naturaleza pero no solo a la naturaleza
como un lugar prístino y de ver paisajes
inmaculados
esta soy yo
ahora de los cuatro años cuando todavía
me gustaba ir a la finca también viene
la transformación de ese campo cercano a
bogotá que atravesó por procesos de
industrialización que cambiaron la forma
en que vivía la gente le dieron más
prosperidad y muchas mayores
oportunidades a quienes ahí vivían
yo tuve la oportunidad de crecer en este
santuario de regresar a él además
mentalmente toda mi vida años después me
iría a vivir ya fuera casi 20 años más
de 20 años y siempre tendría este lugar
este santuario mentalmente y físicamente
para regresar y sentirme en casa
es a ese privilegio con el que yo crecí
es uno que creo que no debería ser un
privilegio sino una oportunidad para
todos y todas los colombianos y lo creo
por dos motivos de manera muy intensa el
primero es que la naturaleza nos hace
mejores personas nos hace tener más
bienestar nos hace más amables nos hace
mejores personas y el segundo porque
creo que el planeta y la humanidad
necesitamos no solamente apreciar y
querer la naturaleza sino saber que es
nuestra mejor oportunidad
empecemos por esta teoría que viene de
la biología evolutiva resulta ser que la
evidencia nos dice que todos los
animales estamos mejor en un hábitat lo
más parecido posible al hábitat en el
que evolucionamos en parte por esto los
animales de zoológico sin importar que
tan buenas sean sus condiciones viven
vidas más cortas
[Música]
y durante muchos años la experiencia ha
estudiado si esto también podría
aplicarse a las personas y resulta que
si vence un minuto para ver estos
paisajes
échense un par de respiradas este es el
río apaporis en nuestra amazonía
este es un hermoso paisaje cercano a la
gota
y estos son los manglares del parque de
los corales aquí más cerca
resulta ser y no sé si hayan tenido la
oportunidad de experimentarlo en esos
brevísimos segundos que a los seres
humanos nos cambia el funcionamiento del
cuerpo simplemente al ver un paisaje
natural ni siquiera tenemos que estar
adentro de él puede ser una imagen puede
ser una ventana nuestra presión arterial
y empieza a bajar y el funcionamiento de
nuestro sistema nervioso pasa del
sistema simple simpático al
parasimpático pasamos de la sensación en
la que vivimos casi todo el tiempo de
estrés huyó o peleó huyó of el hijo huyó
peleó al para siempre simpático donde lo
que estamos pensando es aquí puedo hacer
amigos aquí hay una oportunidad de
cuidarme con otro ser esto pasa
solamente al estar expuestos a un poco
de naturaleza
respiren otra vez sientan como entra su
el sistema parasimpático
esto también aplica socialmente no sólo
físicamente estas son unas torres en la
ciudad de chicago eran 16 torres
gigantescas absolutamente idénticas
todas contenían números muy parecidos de
personas con los años en las torres de
vivienda de interés social hubo algunos
cambios en las áreas verdes algunas
torres quedaron con áreas verdes propias
para disfrutar y para observar y otras
no
un estudio analizó la diferencia en el
tejido social y el conflicto en aquellos
edificios que tenían acceso a zonas
verdes muy sencillas no precisamente las
selvas amazónicas y los que no resulta
que no que los edificios donde si había
zonas verdes había menos conflicto menos
llamadas a la policía por peleas entre
vecinos y además había mejores redes de
cooperación yo te cuida a los niños tú
me cuidas a los niños la tacita de
azúcar va a la tacita de su cambiaria
lo único que se diferenciaba en esos dos
casos era tener acceso al verde
años después un estudio de la
universidad de columbia en la
universidad de pensilvania tomó lotes
baldíos de los que caracterizan a muchas
de nuestras ciudades y simplemente en
estos pequeños lotes hicieron una
sencilla limpieza sembraron pasto un par
de árboles quizás una barca
con poner a funcionar esas áreas verdes
resultó que esos barrios y esas zonas
alrededor tenían una incidencia de menos
9% en los robos de mano al mar
bajaban más del 9 por ciento los
crímenes violentos en esos espacios
pero además de los temas sociales
también hay impacto de la ned
simplemente ver verde psicológico es muy
interesante en londres las farmacias
están planeadas alrededor de barrios tú
tienes una farmacia así que asignada en
términos de cuando te dan una
prescripción médica aislando factores de
ingreso porque por supuesto en el
ingreso también juega un papel
importante aislar los factores de
ingreso aquellos barrios donde hay más
verde verde casual parquecitos y
arbolitos
tienen menores recetas para enfermedades
mentales pues no enfermedad mental es
para situaciones y diagnósticos
psicológicos como la ansiedad y la
depresión los barrios donde hay más
verde parece que hay menos gente ansiosa
y menos gente deprimida
o esto yo no sé decía al final de esos
años en la naturaleza a mí me hicieron
mejor persona más paciente creo que
estoy relativamente feliz y bastante
sana pero sobre todo lo que me dieron a
mí fue un propósito ese amor por la
naturaleza me ha permitido trabajar
desde hace 18 años en temas ambientales
como se imaginarán el trabajo en cuidar
el medio ambiente es enormemente
frustrante y en esos 18 años he querido
darme por vencida muchas veces pero creo
que mentalmente siempre regreso a estos
lugares naturales a mis templos a mis
raíces a lo que me dan un sentido de por
qué hago lo que hago y eso es
maravilloso no hay nada mejor y creo que
lo han visto en todos los que han
hablado hoy trabajar con un sentido de
propósito siempre va a ser mejor y creo
entre más personas allá en el planeta
que tengan ese propósito superior no
solamente querer y cuidar a la
naturaleza que por supuesto hace mucha
falta sino de ver en la naturaleza una
oportunidad desafortunadamente en
colombia tenemos
naturaleza tan abundante que muchas
muchas veces la vemos como el monte que
hay que tumbar o el obstáculo para la
prosperidad y lo que estamos viendo con
el cambio climático con la pérdida
masiva de biodiversidad es que nuestra
mayor oportunidad es nuestra megavideo
biodiversidad ahí es donde está nuestro
futuro probablemente ya no fuimos una
gran sociedad industrializada y no
queramos serlo lo que tenemos que
encontrar en nuestra propia ventaja
comparativa y en la naturaleza está de
verdad nuestra mayor oportunidad
esta frase se le ha asignado a mucha
gente creo haber encontrado su autor
original que es tobías lasser solo
podemos amar aquello que conocemos y
solo podemos proteger aquello que amamos
mi propuesta y mi idea es que integramos
la naturaleza en nuestras vidas
cotidianas que los niños así como
visitan parques y centros culturales
anualmente visitan nuestros parques
naturales que son uno de nuestros
mayores tesoros y no le pertenecen al
gobierno y no le pertenecen a nadie más
que a nosotros es nuestro deber nuestra
obligación y nuestra mejor oportunidad
salir a estos sitios por los que nos
envidian en el mundo entero y algo en
darnos de ellos quererlos y ver todo lo
que nos pueden dar para crecer como país
esto aplica también para nuestra vida
cotidiana si cada vez que estamos un
domingo pensando a ver qué hacemos
acabamos en un centro comercial lo más
probable es que salgamos de ahí
sintiéndonos peor o por haber gastado
mucho o por no tener suficiente para
gastar mucho salgamos a los parques
pueden ser parques de barrios barrios
ustedes tienen esta maravillosa ribera
del río sino que pueden visitar y que
estoy segura que lo hacen todos los días
pero volvamos volvamos lo cotidiano una
cosa que yo no tuve creciendo en esta
oportunidad de sumergirme en el mundo de
una pequeña pantalla
y afortunadamente salí a explorar el
mundo asegurémonos que nosotros y
nuestros hijos también lo hacen pero
también pensamos esta es vivienda de
interés social aquí en montería que fue
entregada hace un par de meses que
desaprovecha la oportunidad de estar
cerca de la naturaleza de tener árboles
de tener verde de asegurarse que esa
naturaleza se convierte en un escape
para que no haya conflictos y es la
evidencia está ahí yo no soy tan hippie
como parezco a veces toda la evidencia
está ahí ella es médica
entonces incorporemos la naturaleza en
nuestra forma de vida la ventaja que
tenemos de botar el mango y que salga el
árbol es una que puede cambiar nuestra
vida cotidiana
este fue mi santuario creciendo yo sé
que fue un lujo y no debería ser un lujo
tener acceso constante a la naturaleza y
la que la naturaleza sea la que nos dé
propósito y paz para seguir adelante con
todas nuestras metas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]